all right i think we're ready for the
next game
okay let's play a ten let's again try to
seek a ten plus five game and we got one
thirteen hundred cool stuff
got a pretty high rated opponent here
let's go with another e4
[Music]
you might also know e5 all right
hopefully here we'll get a chance to
play the
main line for night scotch
knight f3
knight c3
hopefully he goes knight f6 whoa another
five from dr lord mayonnaise thank you
and we go d4 thank you dr lord
mayonnaise
takes takes
in this position i've also played knight
d5 which is called the belgrade gambit
also a very interesting opening
well the normal scotch and and the four
night scots actually don't
have that much in common the the normal
scotch is far more theoretical and
complex
i think this is a simpler opening
and it'll help me illustrate sort of
some basic opening principles
all right
so what's happening here
um
the center has been opened black's main
move is bishop to b4
uh black's second most popular move is
bishop c5 both of those develop the
bishop to an active square
um
of course a lot of be okay there should
be four so he goes for the main line
and now we have to play accurately
because our center is already under a
lot of pressure he's threatening knight
takes e4
pinning the knight we cannot play bishop
d2 here that drops the knight
the first thing we need to do is is
relieve ourselves of the burden
of this pressure we have to trade the
knight
and that will allow us to reinforce the
pawn on e4
a very common i'm assuming he's going to
take with a b pawn
taking with the d-pawn leads to a bad
end game
no bishop takes c3 yeah that's a move
but it's not necessary he tries to
double our pawns
but in return we get our dark square
bishop which is going to be very
valuable in the middle game
and in this this opening is a great
illustration that these doubled isolated
pawns when they're on the queen side
just aren't as important as a lot of
people think they are
okay so
of course we need to defend we need to
defend the pawn and e4 we can consider
going e5 here
but that gets a little bit messy black
and go queen e7 in response so
the classic way to do it in the four
knight statues bishop to d3
you might look at this move and say well
wait a second
isn't the bishop just staring at the
pawn
well yes but again i need to repeat my
favorite phrase bad bishops defend good
pawns and second of all later in the
game of course
we might be able to play e5 then the
bishop is going to be an absolute beast
perhaps some people are attracted to
bishop a3
trying to stop him from castling
i understand that that's appealing the
problem with that move is that black's
going to go d6 and then our bishop is
kind of going to look dumb
so
we could certainly play e5 at this
moment
but then black goes knight d5 sort of
alakine style and
we can keep pushing our pawns and play
c4 in that position
i propose a far more low-key approach
let's start by castling again
let's get our fundamentals in order and
then
we'll start okay now that we have
castled i think e5 is you know i'm far
more comfortable with us playing e5
because we've taken care of the
immediate needs of the position for some
reason our opponent is not playing d6
and we can try to punish him for that e5
opening up the bishop
and clamping down on the position now
in this position we have to play
accurately because
what does black want to do on the next
move first of all this pawn is under
attack that's not the most important
threat
what black wants to do is go d6
undermine our central pawn and open up
the bishop so
we have sort of one or two moves we have
this small window where the bishop is
not developed and we have this clamp on
black's position we've got a lot of
stuff aimed at black's king
so
you should kind of already be putting
your attacking hat on and thinking about
various moves like bishop takes h6 here
which doesn't work
um
like queen g4 which x-rays the king
a queen g4 is a very reasonable move
but what does queen g4 run into
hey it doesn't lose to d6 it just runs
into d6
but if you calculate one move further if
we drop our queen back to g3 there white
still has a very reasonable position
very good attack
but
for that very reason i like the move
queen h5 better than queen g4 because
this of course
sets up a sacrifice on h6 which may or
may not happen
uh and it also just brings the queen
closer to the king side so we can even
go queen five at some point the question
might be well aren't we worried about
the c pawn and the answer to that is
absolutely not we don't care about this
pawn this spawn is serving absolutely no
purpose
uh let him take it and waste more moves
it's well i i don't really like that
it's doubled anyway logic it's more that
even if it wasn't doubled even if we
didn't have a pawn on c2 we wouldn't
care about it
because we're going for checkmate
we're threatening mate kind of we're
threatening a potentially devastating
sacrifice on h6 which has to be
calculated
you're asking what if black defends well
well that's always a risk when you're
sacrificing something i just trust in
the attack here what's black's best
defense here uh that's a good question i
think d6 might be a good try
then the sacrifice on h6 is far from
one-sided and
if he does that we'll spend some time
calculating the lines there
but
against d6 we might very well want to
refrain from sacking on h6 for the time
being
and and play something like f4
securing the pawn on e5
yeah it seems like he's taking a long
think here that's kind of a sign of
panic
there's a lot of uh interesting lines in
this in this position this will allow me
to talk about
basic sacrifices and attacking
whoa
night now that is not something
any of us could have predicted
okay we will take that thank you
thank you for the knights
well that's a pretty extreme way of
dealing with at least he stopped bishop
takes h6
at least he stopped bishop takes these
things thank you brighton bryden francis
for the prime
but okay we're a piece up let's let's be
serious let's try to
finish this off in style
no this is uh this is not practical this
just loses the game
okay
no i think i think maybe it was the
lesser evil but i still don't like it
yeah i like bishop d2 here just develop
the bishop defend the pawn
now in our mind we need to kind of
switch and say now he's attacking c3 and
now that we've already won a piece
there's no need to give up any further
material
there's absolutely no need to give up
any further material if it's i mean it
might be the top engine move because
he's so busted due to the threat of
bishop takes h6 but i don't think so
whoa nemo with a raid party of 817 oh my
goodness damn girl
welcome everybody we're doing a speed
run you come at a good time we're in the
middle of a speed run game
the speed run is an instructional
exercise that i do where i basically
climb
from the beginner level and explain all
of my moves
thank you nemo for the 19 months
okay so we're currently playing a game
here with the white pieces we're up a
piece
and we're trying to convert our
advantage
what do we do now we play very natural
moves of course we want to put a rook on
e1 that's the only open file i guess the
b file is also open
which rook do we want to put on f1
anyone i don't think it matters
but i i don't always like this situation
i don't like when one of the rooks is
kind of locked
behind the other rook and so let's
player cafe one i also don't care about
the f2 pawn getting a little vulnerable
he's not attacking it with anything
other than the queen
um
so in these situations i always get a
questions from people like why not trade
queens why not go queen e5 and queen e5
would be a totally legitimate way to
convert the advantage
uh but
as i always say i don't think the
presence of queens is necessarily going
to make it harder for us to convert the
advantage thank you michigan for the 11
months in fact here i think we can go
directly for checkmate
yeah let's go
absolutely we are lifting that rook up
to g3 maybe to f3
depends on what black does
and we are basically going for plan one
which is using your extra material and
converting it directly into an attack
against the opponent's king
thank you huber title for the prime so
many subs today
rook ae8
okay
rook f3 is good rook f3 kind of forces a
queen trade with queen e5 but
you know i like rook g3 here threatening
queen takes h6
or bishop takes h6
the problem is that after king a trade
i'm not seeing
a a direct method of of winning the game
so we might have to play a little bit
more slowly
oh you were trolling about the rook lift
akilah
see how good you are even when you're
trolling okay rookie
is tantamount
to collapse
of course we don't take on h6 with the
bishop and give up our queen
we play queen takes h6
this is not just a queen trade because
if you calculate a little further after
the queens are traded black has huge
problems with the g7 pawn which simply
cannot be defended
and the game is essentially over
yeah unfortunately our opponent didn't
let us demonstrate
anything
more than a straightforward attack but
nonetheless
there's a lot to talk about after the
game
well i actually don't know if that he
had a better defense to be honest i
think black was kind of busted already
yeah just don't forget about these moves
you know when a pawn is pinned it can't
move
so anytime there's a rook pin
uh whatever the pinned pawn is defending
is now not defended so
you you need to be aware of that
all right
so we're threatening to take on g7 with
either the rook or the bishop
this is completely completely winning if
g6 then we take the rook on f8
and then we're up before rock
yeah probably thought he tried okay
rookie eight
so immediately we should notice that
rookie one is not a mate threat
so even if we miss rookie one we'll be
okay because we can cover with the
bishop in the end
does that mean we want to allow rookie
one
absolutely not i mean why would we
bend over backwards when we can just
create some loft but before we create
any lift let's take on g7 first order of
business
and then let's create some lift so
what i just did there right i started
automatically playing h3 then i thought
wait a second
if we want to play mega precisely we
know that it's the end game
we know that on the one hand pass pawns
are meant to be pushed on the other hand
if you're
if you're looking at this closely you
might see that rook h5 is a bit of a
nasty idea
hitting the bishop and you see the
problem right if the bishop moves away
then we lose the rook
so if we really want to be scientific
about this what can we do
how can we create loft and
simultaneously parry the threat
completely unnecessary move completely
unnecessary move but just showing you
what is possible we can go g4 this is
dual purpose the one-handed stop strike
h5 on the other hand it prepares the
move g5 which will anchor the bishop and
keep the rook safe
now i talked about this in in the last
video in game the the idea that when
beginners create luft they only play h3
but that's not the only way to do it
especially in the end game
so if a different move such as g3 or f3
you know accomplishes something don't be
afraid to make that kind of move
yeah there's no maid in the corner rook
h7 king g8 and
i i'm sure we'll create a mating that
but it's not quite there yet
rookie six and there we go
um and now we can reap the benefits of
this move we can also play rook takes f7
and counter attack the bishop anything
wins here
but
i'm just gonna prove the point
that g4 was helpful we could play g5
i know some people are probably thinking
but isn't the bishop trapped on h6
well and this is hard for me to explain
it is but we're just so winning that
we're going to reach we don't even need
anything other than the rook and the
bishop we don't even really need this
rook on a1 to participate
we're going to get the bishop out of
there
and one one way of doing that is rook h7
and bishop g7
so it's just totally winning
in in in either case
i have a forced repetition that's true
but i don't think we're taking it
it restricts the rook but
it's like the rug doesn't need to go
back anyway all we need to do with the
rook is either give a check on h7 or
take on f7
where it matters it's not it's not
restrictive
thank you man totor for the 11
months no stockfish could not draw this
against me there's
no superhuman
force you can possibly draw this
yeah mata promise yeah rook takes f7 of
course is also completely winning
but we are basically going for checkmate
as we'll see
i'm sure about that yeah
um
another thing that i mention is i would
call this the diminishing returns
theory of chess
so
i've talked about this before but now
i've kind of formalized it
when you win a piece right when you win
a bishop it's huge like the position
goes from equal to completely winning
when you win a second bishop or a second
minor piece the position goes from
you know quite a bit winning to totally
completely winning
but then for every additional pawn that
you win
it adds a lot less to your decisive
advantage than the initial piece right
and that's the basically the diminishing
returns idea in general
let's take an f7
he he wants to play bishop h3 but then
we're going to give a check on g7
um and i think that applies very
directly to material advantage right
of course if there are free pawns you
should take them even if you're up a
queen
but you shouldn't go out of your way
and damage your position to take an
extra pawn an additional pawn
bishop h3 let's go bishop g7 check
for sure black has king g8 and we're
going to have a trade of rooks
but at the end we can even push the g
pawn forward with g6 and then we can go
f4 and anchor anchor the bishop on e5
this is just totally totally winning
maybe not the smoothest technique but
i mean
it really doesn't matter i was just
curious who's right who ray is playing
let's go four first
we are certainly not in a rush to play
g6 that's not going to be stopped by
black
thank you thank you zen morphe
okay now we can go g6
and then finally we can activate this
rook where do we go with the rook we use
the b file we go rook b1 rook b8 i
always love when a piece that has not
been playing the whole game just kind of
waits out you know the world war and
then just emerges and reaps all the
benefits and looks good
exactly takes all the credit like newton
and calculus
okay what do we do now well
we can't go rook b8 but we can go rook
b7
and then rotate c7 and whatever
i do love taking puns
who doesn't
yeah he's gonna lose on time
okay rook rook c8
now the most accurate here is to notice
that the rook is no longer x-raying the
bishop or whatever pressuring the bishop
so now we can start pushing the f-pawn
which is totally over extending black
j left thank you
f6 i mean this is totally resignable
and it resigns yeah timeout
okay good game
good
game so you can see that the four knight
scotch is far from innocuous far from
toothless bishop takes e3 is inaccurate
so the main line by the way continues bc
then we go bishop d3 now black can do
this in any order black and castle first
the traditional move is to go d5 here
then we have a trait of pawns in the
center
white castles black castles and white
gets the bishop out to g5 this is
sort of the the
traditional main line of the four night
scotch and then we get our queen out to
f3 and put more pressure on the knight
and uh and the line goes on i'm sure
we'll have a chance to
to play this out maybe at a slightly
higher rating
um yeah questions of course so ask the
question as we get to that moment in the
game
thank you
chanky for the tier one
okay so we go bishop d3
and his mistake main mistake was not to
play
d6
in general this is kind of a
a general concept the idea of sort of
pushing one of your central pawns
further in the opening and clamping down
i don't know of any better word than
clamping down on your opponent's
position and then removing that clamp
frequently
requires making serious concessions
and you can see this play out on even at
grandmaster level
where
neglecting to push one of these pawns
can lead to
majorly
unpleasant consequences i have a good
example of that
for you from a famous game
now this game is very well known for the
combination that ended it
um
but it's
it's less known for the opening but in
my opinion the opening is quite
instructive
the trojan against pacman
bachmann was was a
gm
and
let me see if i can pull this game up
for you
thank you uh
let's see
uh tigran the world champion yeah
not not not this the grand protection
patron pachmann uh
and this is a simple illustration of
this
black played this game very poorly
very poorly for a gm but still it's it's
worth uh
worth looking at so knight f3
c5 petrossian plays a kingzinian attack
okay bachmann plays normally d36 this is
a setup i've talked about many many
times where the bishop is fianchetto and
the knight in order to not disturb the
diagonal goes to e7 rather than f6
petrossian goes rookie one and here we
go
pachmann automatically castles
where but it turns out to be very
serious mistake why
what does petrossian do
the correct move here was to go d6
yeah petrossian says all right i'm going
to go e5 and i'm going to clamp down on
your dark squares
now poffman probably thought this was
not a problem because now he goes d6 and
he says all right well we trade pawns
what's the big deal well the big deal is
that now black has all of these
sort of weaknesses in the position the
knight's got coming to e4 the pawn on c5
is weak so black has to waste a move to
get the queen back and petrossian just
starts getting all of his pieces in with
tempo bishop and bishop comes in
knight comes into e5 and before you know
it black is just
completely paralyzed
um
now
the game ends very quickly because
poffin just gets destroyed here queen f3
and in this position petrossian had a
a very very beautiful combination which
he played on the next move the trojan
goes rookie four
and after rook d80 sees the combination
who knows
what the solution is i i'm sure that
probably somebody in the chat has seen
this before
yeah it's queen takes f6 it's not insane
king takes f6 now you give another check
and the most famous move the combination
is this one
this is the move that makes this
combination famous
because it's one of those very stylish
quiet moves
nope
yup maximus got it brilliant strike got
it the move is bishop to g7 there might
be other ways to mate this is the
fastest because it prevents the king
from escaping to h6
and it creates essentially the
unstoppable threat of h4 for example
let's make a random move
h4 check
if king h5 then bishop f3 is checkmate
and if king f5
then also bishop h3 or knight e3 or a
million other moves
um
yeah so these quiet moves after you've
sacrificed your queen are
absolutely stunning i have something to
share with you guys that's
truly incredible it's from
uh from an analysis that i've done
and it features a similar concept of
sacrificing the queen and then following
up with an incredible quiet move even
brandon might find this interesting
um
i don't know if you guys want to see it
i i won't show you guys the entire prep
line uh and this has been published in
new and chess yearbook so
it's not completely a secret
okay now let me find it really really
fast
okay i think this is good so this is
from the karo khan um
it basically it comes from this crazy
line where white sacrificed the piece
and um
as you can see black's king is like
stuck in the center
and
what what starts this is this move c4
you're basically breaking through
d takes c4 d5
this is understandable you're creating
this diagonal but after bishop takes d5
one of white's possibilities is
absolutely insane i'll let you guys take
a stab at it
there i mean this sequence is absolutely
remarkable
the first move is a queen sacrifice
so here's the thing knight h7 would be
checkmate
if if the rook on e1 had controlled the
e7 square
so you might think about it well what is
that involved that involves getting rid
of
well you can't take on e6 that doesn't
help queen f5 check
now
black can take the queen in two
different ways if king e7 you take the
bishop
um
e takes f5 is checkmate
the problem though is king takes f5
right black takes with the king and okay
you have a bunch of checks here but
nothing seems to work like if you give
this check
then then king up back to f6
if you go g4 check
then again king comes back to f6
but in this position you might spot an
interesting idea if the knight on g5 was
replaced by a bishop that would be
checkmate so knight e4 check bishop
takes c4 bishop g5 is me
of course black is just going to tuck
the king away on e7
so we have to find a move that gets the
knight out of g5 and simultaneously
prepares g4 and bishop g5 made and this
beautiful move is knight to e4
okay so a lot of you are thinking about
knight h7 and i think the reason knight
h7 doesn't work there is a reason
just give me a second to think about it
yeah knight h7 bishop takes f3 knight h7
bishop takes f3
and and g4 is no longer checkmate
because the bishop takes g4
so you play knight e4 and some of the
lines are just beautiful
okay so
first of all if bishop takes e4
g4 check king f6 bishop g5 mate
black is a draw by the way here only
move that draws the game
black can try the movie five
with the idea of opening up the e6
square for the king here the checkmate
is absolutely stunning
absolutely stunning checkmate in this
position
and it is
i actually have to remember it
what is the mates
yeah
i i remember it so you go g4 check
no if you go g4 check yeah king e6 and
black's king escapes black's king
escapes no no no no now the king runs
the e7
you go knight d4 check
in order to open up the e file now you
go g4
if k6 then there is a beautiful mate
knight g5 check
king f6 knight h7 mate
look at this mate
if king e5
then you simply go knight c3 check i
mean black can play bishop before it
doesn't help essentially you checkmate
like this
yeah there's like a different made for
every move
so that's e5 if knight e5 to cover the
g4 square then knight d4 is checkmate
another amazing mate
if knight f6
then knight takes d6 and then knight t4
again is made
black has an only move to draw the game
and that's bishop takes g3
and white has to force the draw by
perpetual here with with knight d4
king e5 knight back to f3
but this is an amazing line and this
queen sack actually occurs in several
different lines within this variation
this is real i mean this is this is not
occurred in tournament play but it is
from
uh legitimate analysis
um
well i hope everybody was able to follow
at least the mating patterns
if he took the knight well i already
showed this if he took the knight then
g4 checked the king has only one square
and bishop g5 is checkmate
yeah i'm sure actually finding the draw
is not that hard for black if you just
use process of elimination
you can look at every legal move
until you
figure out one where you against which
you can't find the mate
[Music]
i don't necessarily practice these
positions per se this came from opening
analysis it was not intentionally
constructed
anyways i hope you enjoyed that little
uh
foray into
into uh chess beauty
all right
how did i find this well
obviously i was working with an engine
uh and
i i had the idea of going queen f5 in
various positions it didn't work for a
while and then
ultimately you know because of these c4
d5 moves it somehow changes the position
so the sac actually works
[Music]